I am from Bermuda,
and so we wore school uniforms.
In high school,
I went on a crusade
to allow women to wear pants.
So I've always been
very focused on
the narrative
that our clothing takes.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
I'm Shiona Turini,
and I am the costume designer
of Insecure.
I always wanted to work
in fashion,
there was no other option
for me.
I moved to New York,
and I started to work in
the editorial capacity,
and then I did a few
music videos here and there.
I was one of the stylists
for Beyoncé's "Formation,"
Solange Knowles' "Cranes,"
and "Don't Touch My Hair."
Eventually I was put on a job
with Issa Rae.
And they contacted me
to see if I would be interested
in costume designing
for Insecure.
And I said yes.
It is such an honor to be
with a team that's led by
so many women,
especially women of color.
As a black woman,
diversity is always top of mind.
We try and include
black designers
on every single episode.
It's important and it's
our social responsibility
to make sure that we are
highlighting talented people
on and off camera.
When I started at Insecure,
the aesthetics
of the main characters
were pretty much already
carved out,
which was a unique challenge,
because I continued
that narrative,
but added my own personal touch.
I feel deeply connected
to the material.
It's telling our stories
as black women.
It's just an honor
to be a part of that team
that is releasing this baby
into the world.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪